I had to give my debit card to my wife
I had to take it out of my possession
because I didn't control myself I
couldn't control myself
and mine was always taking people to
lunch oh I got it let's go to lunch
let's go to lunch go to lunch I'll go
get coffee let's go grab dinner
and so it wasn't shoes and shirts as
much as it was I was trying to buy
connection with people because I didn't
think people would want to hang out with
me just to hang out and so I had to take
radical steps I disconnected Amazon
Prime I didn't have access to it I
changed the code I didn't have access I
couldn't get in
and I didn't have my debit card so I
couldn't just go buy things willy-nilly
I had some cash in my wallet and that's
what I used to spend when it was gone it
was gone
but there's some really easy steps you
can take to make it to where I can you
can't just buy stuff